auf motivsuche im ewigen eis der
fotograf norbert rosing nimmt für
spektakuläre bilder - temperaturen von
bis zu 38 grad celsius in kauf
auf solche szenen wie in der kanadischen
provinz manitoba wartet er manchmal
mehrere wochen
[Musik]
seine besten bilder sind jetzt in dem
buch erschienen
die schönheit des hohen norden
festgehalten indisch kochen scharfen
bildern
seit 30 jahren reiste naturfotograf in
den norden polarkreis
[Musik]
in seinem haus in der nähe von münchen
erinnert sich rosing an außergewöhnliche
begegnungen etwa mit einer schweren
familie schlief die route war mit den
jungs und dann fing sie beugt sich mit
denen an zu spielen und dann ist die
temperatur innerhalb von einer stunde
von -30 auf minus 8 gestiegen
und plötzlich fing es an zu regnen dann
merkten wir plötzlich für die bären
anfängt ihre jungen trocken zu legen
weil die wurden ja alle last und das war
sehr gefährlich dann stand sie plötzlich
auf die kleinen wollen anfangen zu sagen
und dann war für zwei sekunden sagen
diese momente für die arbeit mit den
scheuen tieren gibt es im nationalpark
von manitoba klage wegen das
fotografieren ist ruhe in der brücke
unter leitung eines schülers erlaubt und
man darf sich den tieren bis auf 100
meter nähern aber nicht mehr laufen weg
fahren doch nicht hinterher
also wir können nur mit denen bären
arbeiten die uns engagieren heißt wir
sitzen bleiben und auch ganz schnell ex
spiel dadurch haben wir die situation
dass wir eine bären viele funktionen
haben norbert rosing gibt die analoge
fotografie und hat viele bilder noch auf
film aufgenommen
hier prüft er die mit motiven lange
reisen nach kanada und grönland
dann kam halt die einführung der
digitalfotografie in den nullerjahren
und ich habe mich sehr sehr lange
verweigert und bin auch nie ein
richtiger fan des ganzen geworden
das wird heute mit der fotografie
gemacht wird kann ich zum großteil nicht
nachvollziehen weil es weil ich habe
einfach die authentische fotografie
er fotografiert auch gern in seiner
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft am
bayerischen ammersee besonders liebt er
die winterlandschaften ihn interessiert
wie unberührte natur
mein thema ist das wilde deutschland so
wie es aber vor 102 jahren gewesen ist
davon sind nur noch kleine in denn da
aber diese inventur wieder bedroht durch
neueste technologien und so weiter und
ich versuche den menschen zu zeigen
leute so sieht es im moment aus lasst es
uns bewahren auch für die nächsten
zumindest in zwei drei jahren erfahrung
rosins bilder wurden auch in
renommierten magazinen wie geo und
national geographic abgedruckt so waren
die deutsche post nutzte seine motive
für briefmarkenserie regelmäßig besucht
er die eisbären den münchner tierpark
hellabrunn als un-botschafter setzt sich
norbert rosing für biologische vielfalt
und artenschutz ein häufig fotografiert
er hier den beispiel im juli sehr
häufigen nachwuchs also ich komme ganz
gerne info weil erstens kommissäre
gebären heran und zweitens vergleich ich
sehr gerne
wie sehen die bern draußen aus in der
natur und lilien im forum
[Musik]
live-bilder aus der wurfhöhle mit dem
neuen eisbärjungen können sich besucher
schon jetzt im jahr kann sich im märz
das junge dann seinen ersten auftritt im
gehege haben
für norbert rosing aber geht es bald
schon wieder in die arktis
dort will er in ewigen eis magische
momente einfangen
die man so vielleicht nicht mehr lange
sehen
[Musik]